[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi,
I'm Jessica and I'm
going to be talking about
a chemical demonstration
today that I like to call
"Death of a Gummy Bear."
We eat these little
guys all the time
and our bodies
break down the sugar
in a series of
chemical reactions.
But what happens when you break
down the sugar in a gummy bear
outside of our bodies?
Well, MIT'S Dr. John
Dolhun is going to show us.
Here he is at the Cambridge
Science Festival at MIT.
JOHN DOLHUN: Now I'm
going to actually
be combusting a gummy candy.
And my wife said, please
don't tell them it's a bear.
Guess what?
It's a bear.
And I'm going to
eat one right now.
And I'm eating a gummy candy.
It's sugar.
And I'm going to chew on it, and
eat it, and what do you think's
going to happen to it?
AUDIENCE: It's
going to break down.
JOHN DOLHUN: It's going to
break down into carbon dioxide.
Tomorrow I'm going to
be breathing out CO2.
I'm going to be perspiring.
Water is going to be coming out.
And I'm going to
make a lot of energy,
and I'm going to take that
energy and store it up as ATP,
and it's going to help me clean
all these dishes tomorrow.
I don't want to think
about that but I'm
going to need the energy.
And now I'm going to
do this same reaction
inside of a test tube.
And I want you to compare
what you just saw.
You didn't see a lot
of smoke and fire
coming out of my mouth, did you?
Not yet, OK.
So Clifton, you can.
Clifton's going to play
a little rondo or music
while I set this reaction up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: So what
is Dr. Dolhun doing?
First, he put some solid
potassium chlorate in a test
tube and heated it up.
The heat causes the solid
to melt and become a liquid.
So this little
triangle means heat.
It turned from a
solid to a liquid.
As it's being heated, the liquid
potassium chlorate immediately
starts breaking down into two
products, potassium chloride
and oxygen. Now potassium
chloride is a solid
and the oxygen is a gas.
Looks like this.
Now let's see what happens when
Dr. Dolhun adds the gummy bear.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's break down
what just happened.
The sugar from the
gummy bear and oxygen
reacted to produce
carbon dioxide and water,
releasing a lot of
energy as heat and light.
This is what that
looks like, and I'm
going to draw sucrose,
or sugar, in red
because it's from
the gummy bear.
This reaction is
probably familiar to you.
It's a combustion
reaction, which
is when a fuel reacts with
oxygen to produce carbon
dioxide and water and at
the same time, releasing
a bunch of energy.
So why is so much
energy released
and where does it come from?
To show you, I'm going
to draw the structures.
Now, if you're unfamiliar with
organic chemistry notation,
each of the lines between the
elements that I'm going to draw
represents a
covalent bond, which
is the sharing of two
electrons between two atoms.
So let me draw those.
So here are the reactants
and here are the products.
Now by looking at the number
of bonds and the type of bonds,
so a carbon bonded to an
oxygen, or a carbon bonded
to a carbon, and a single
bond versus a double bond,
you can calculate
the energy difference
between the left side of
the reaction, the reactants,
and the right side,
or the products.
Now all combustion
reactions have more energy
stored in the reactants
than the products,
so as the reaction progresses,
this energy has to go somewhere
and it's released
as heat and light.
Now the amount of energy
released from this explosion
is exactly the same as
the amount of energy
that would be
released in my body
when I eat this gummy bear.
The difference is that
proteins in my body
are set up in pathways
that extract the energy
in small, manageable bundles.
So I power my
everyday activities
like dancing and running,
but I don't explode.
Evolution has trained
biological systems
to efficiently extract
energy from our environment.
That's it for me today.
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]